I've been giving you my time
and I make ice tea and I make it when
you love it
Justin Bieber showing fans how far he's
come since revealing a serious health
issue last year it's an amazing feeling
last June the singer told fans he had
Ramsay Hunt Syndrome a rare condition
that paralyzed one side of his face it
is from this
virus
that um
attacks the nerve in my ear
and my facial
nerves
and has caused my face to have paralysis
as you can see this eye is not blinking
I can't smile on this side of my face
Justin's condition forced him to cancel
his tour at the time and he shared he
was doing all he can to get back on
stage doing all these facial exercises
to
get my face back to normal and um
it will go back to normal it's just time
and we don't know how much time it's
going to be but it's gonna be
it's gonna be okay and I have hope fast
forward nine months Justin's proudly
making progress he captions the video
wait for it then begins moving his eyes
side to side smiling from ear to ear I'm
having a good time Justin's health
update comes amid his recent internet
drama involving his wife Haley and
ex-girlfriend Selena Gomez oh my
goodness fans speculated Haley and Kylie
Jenner were making fun of Selena on
Instagram after cell shared this clip
referencing her newly done brows I
accidentally laminated my brows too much
not long after Kylie posted this snap
writing this was an accident over her
brows and shared a close-up pic of
Haley's brows then there was this
resurface clip on drop the mic
Hollywood's top Stars face off in a
one-on-one rap battle full of the
meanest lyrics about a celebrity since
Taylor Swift's last album
after this moment went viral on Tick
Tock cell came to her bestie Taylor
Swift's defense in the comments writing
so sorry my best friend is and continues
to be one of the best in the game I'm
very honest though in general but all
this online chatter hasn't affected the
Beavers or so the source tells E.T
Justin and Haley are doing fine and have
no plans of addressing it quote Justin
knows that speaking publicly about it
will only amplify the situation and
bring more attention to it so they have
been supporting each other privately I
just don't want to like I don't want to
read stuff because I don't want to read
negative stuff and then be upset as for
Selena well our source says she's
staying in her Lane and doing her own
thing I'm at that age where I feel like
that's what matters is making sure I'm
healthy and people are happy that I love
and if any fans hope Jelena would ever
be a thing again
ET Source says there's no chance that
chapter has closed for both of them
[Music]
thank you